[Music]
every time you find yourself here it's
because you chose to come back
[Music]
hello my name is mark s
[Music]
and i have of my own free accord elected
to undergo the procedure
known as severance
i give consent to sever my memories
between my work life
and my personal life
i acknowledge that once the procedure is
complete i will be unable to access my
personal memories whilst on the severed
floor say gratitude
nor will i retain work memories
sorry when i return home
at the end of the day
i make these statements freely
hi kids what's for dinner we warned you
about the greeting you were kidding we
hate it how many reasons did we come up
with eight
good morning hi mr mill check mark could
i have a word petey
is no longer with this company i'm sorry
mark you guys are one of my favorite
office friendships what happened we'd
love to tell you but unfortunately
non-disclosure policy forbids i confer
upon you the advanced role of department
chief congratulations a handshake is
available upon request
thank you may i have a handshake
do i know you my name's petey i'm from
work
so we're friends
i'm your best friend
nothing
is what they say
i used to think it would take a monster
to put someone in a place like that
office
especially if the person was himself
if you want to know what's going on down
there
you'll find the beginning
of a very long answer
what's happening
what is it we actually do here
[Music]
it's important your eyes be kind do you
know how to make your eyes kind of
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you